all right good morning
all right are there any preliminary
matters before the jury comes in
if you could put your microphone on or
go to the
okay that's fine
all right anything else preliminary
no thank you your honor okay we're good
we're ready for the jury all right let's
bring the jury out
oh sorry
do you want to wait for the jury then
you can enter those into evidence is
that okay you enter those exhibits into
evidence when the jury comes out
does that sound all right
that works okay that works okay
uh
all right
good morning ladies and gentlemen
all right
mr mr nadel hoff did you have um
ladies and you might remember we're in
the middle of dr kipper's testimony for
per deposition but i think there's some
exhibits that need to be moved in
i thank your honor uh the parties
discussed over the over the weekend and
we have agreement as to plaintiff's
exhibits
41
42
47
48 and 49 of plaintiff's exhibits
i do believe that there are some
slight redactions that i think they have
copies of that they can provide to you
and then we also have defendants
10 1063
which is redacted and i can provide you
a copy and
they also have the redactions okay um
same for defendants 283
defendants 405
defendants 455
defendants 304
defendants
307 and in addition
um
395
and 414
would come in without any redactions but
i can provide you copies of the ones
that we all right and have you already
done the redactions are you still
working on redactions
uh your honor we have agreed on the
redactions except for one document which
we will okay
and now 42 i already have an evidence
i was just waiting for redactions for
that one so we're still waiting for
redactions for that one correct or do
you have that for me uh so 42 is i
believe defendant
defendant's 42.
oh i think we decided we agreed that for
that one that there would be no no
redactions
plain is 42. sorry plane is 42 we have
no reaction after discussion that there
would be no reduction okay gotcha that's
correct okay
all right so all those are entered into
evidence is that correct with the
redactions that you've agreed upon
yes there are all right so there's no
objection and there's yes there's no
objection okay
if i may did you address ours i think i
addressed yours
all right and we can provide you would
you so they have the they have the
electronic copies which can be are going
to be shown while the definition is
being played and we can provide these
copies i can provide you copies now of
the redacted right if they're redacted
ones i need copies if they're not
redacted i have them right so yes okay
okay that'll be fine all right thank you
all right
all right i think we're ready
thank you
if i may just before we begin your honor
okay
just as an explanation for the jury um
what you have seen from dr kipper up
until this point has been miss heard's
counsel examining him
um at some point it'll switch over and
it'll be uh mr depp's council examining
him all right thank you
mr depp uh
informing you that he was upset with dr
cowan
yeah yes i i
remember
clearly that he was upset with dr cowan
at a certain point
you know do you recall this text message
from mr
depp that i just read to you
yes
in reading it i do okay
and then
mr depp wrote you again on july 5th 2015
and said you're a great man and a great
friend as much as i would love to see
you dot dot dot be a waste of your time
dot dot dot i've just got quite a lot
going on with my with business stuff my
keith film and some amber issues dot dot
dot by the way i'll try not to be too
subtle about this dot dot dot cowen
should be stripped of his license to
practice his supposed profession dot dot
dot and then he should be stripped and
spray painted wills handcuffed to a stop
sign
three exclamation points he is at best a
fraudulent irresponsible turd of
monumental proportions three exclamation
points i love you johnny you recall this
text message from mr deck
again i i do upon reading this i
i don't remember all the specific
messages i got from him but i certainly
uh remember the gestalt of his feelings
okay and and do you continue to work
with dr cowan you continue to refer
patients to dr cowan let me ask it
differently yes
i have great respect for dr cal
and
uh mr depp sent you another text message
on july 24th 2015 that says hey dear pal
amber is happy happy with cowan dot dot
dot i just don't know what truth he gets
and i don't know what his manners and
strengths are dot dot dot i think she
listens to him because when she we argue
she slathers me up in those
condescending psychiatric trophy lines
like dot dot dot your fear is so visible
dot dot what are you scared of dot dot
dot three exclamation points why are you
letting your fear and your ego control
your life
etc dot dot hippie [ __ ] dot dot dot
makes me want to rampage against anyone
all capitals wearing birkenstocks three
exclamation points love you large j
i assume you recall this text message as
well
no but i
i recall when when i'm looking at it yes
okay
um
now i'm going to go to another text
message
on
august 3rd 2015 mr depp texts you
you can flog me soon for waiting until
now for having not to properly given my
kind apparatus the appropriate and
adequate general [ __ ] love
dot dot i've tried and mostly fail dot
dot dot many many unpleasant things
happening with my business world going
on that are attempting to give me the
funny pained face that could render me
no more and send me head first straight
into the bowl of minestrone or worse a
green curry dot dot dot so most
necessary prns are all headache meds
xanax adderall and whatever this magical
ointment for that traitorous redness in
the much valued in region of
significance dot dot dot thanks and love
xjd um
do you recall this text message
no but i'm
once again reminded by looking at it
you recall not being paid for three
months
i recall not being paid i don't remember
how long and um
it always it always turned back around
but
specifically that issue no i can't give
you specifics
so there was a
period of time where
mr depp was not paying you for your
services correct
correct
okay so as of
february
10 2016 you were very concerned about mr
mr depp's health correct
in the document
i'm
also serving as his internist managing
some medical issues
and that that's the nature of these
concerns
you weren't concerned at all about mr
depp's uh
continuing with his uh
treatment plan for
drug and alcohol use
you can't separate those two issues
they're not two distinct issues
but in order for me to assess how he was
doing in general with his general health
these metrics that i identify in the
second paragraph were things that i
needed to
have follow up on
and i wasn't
i wasn't getting that follow-up and i
needed to know
that
we were on the right course medically
and you recall being concerned about mr
depth in june 2018
yes
what if any concerns that you have about
mr depp taking drugs or alcohol that
were not part of the protocol i was
concerned that that could be potentially
an issue
dr kipper
kipper 28.
your honor at this point there's an
exhibit at which the parties are um
still in dispute um i believe it's okay
to continue playing at this point and we
can resolve it all right after the fact
is that yeah we can resolve it after the
deficit okay
all right that's fine thank you
our
invoices that you produced
from february 2015 through from february
20 february 6 2015 to february 1st 2021.
you recall producing these documents
no
those would have come from my
accountant's office okay are you are you
still um
working for mr dapp
yes okay
and so
at the bottom here there's a lot that
just say case management fee
um do you know what that refers to as
opposed to nursing services and doctor
services
that's a retainer fee that i have with
him um on a monthly basis now
dr kipper we received invoices for you
for mr depp from fireman's insurance
fund um for 2014. does this look like an
invoice from from your
office to mr depp
dr kipper you would just you've already
testified that these are invoices to mr
deb correct
i've testified that these are invoices
this is something generated from my
account
yes
have you um
spoken to mr legal counsel
since the beginning of this year
um yes
who have you spoken from now
i've spoke i've spoken to
camille um on two occasions
anybody else
nope
what did you speak to camille about
about the deposition mr dr kim bradzik
you're incorrect i think also uh ms
myers uh was in one of those telephone
conversations
that's right
and um other than the scheduling of the
deposition did what did they talk about
the issues that you were going to be
asked about
yes of course okay how long were the
conversations
45 minutes each
were they uh over phone or by zoom or in
person
the first conversation was in person
and this the second was bison
and you thought there were about two
45-minute calls
about that
our
um are you paying for your council in
this case
yes i am
first of all uh dr kipper do you
remember seeing this document earlier
yes
and you recognize it as your
initial consultation notes with mr deb
yes
um i'd like to direct your attention to
the third page
excuse me
one moment okay
um you see here where it
says impressions
yes
now
what could you describe what the items
listed under this heading are
so the first one
primary dopamine imbalance
[Music]
this in general terms i don't know
primary dopamine imbalance adhd which is
attention deficit hyperactivity disorder
bipolar one
depression secondary to above insomnia
chronic substance abuse disorder
chronic reflux
with respect to these items are these an
official diagnosis of mr death
these are my impressions yes
um
when you say impression is that
considered a diet would you consider
that a diagnosis
yes miss myers that's my diagnostic
impression
i'd like to pull up what's already been
marked as uh kipper exhibit four please
and
dr kipper um
i believe we've already established but
could you confirm that you recognize
these documents this document
yes
and these are also um notes of the
consultation you had with mr dub
correct
um
do you and it appears from these notes
that missed uh debbie lloyd was at the
meeting correct yes
and
she's a registered nurse
yes
and
did mr duff's treatment plan uh
contemplate
miss floyd
remaining with mr duck during his
therapy
yes
and was it contemplated that miss lloyd
would personally distribute his
medications to him
did miss lloyd provide personally
dispensed
medications to mr duff
yes she did
and
how
and
how regular was miss lloyd's contact
with mr death
she had contact with him daily
either physically or by phone
how often would you estimate that she
was physically in contact with him
i would say 80
90
of the time somewhere in there
and mr duff agreed to this supervision
by miss lloyd
yes
um alex could we please pull up what's
been marked as kimber exhibit 6.
um
dr kipper could you please confirm that
these are your notes from um a
consultation you had with mr duff in
boston in june of 2014.
yes this is a summary from june 22nd to
june 24th of that concept
of that time with him
and
if we scroll down i guess
the notes reflect here that you met with
miss heard at that time correct
yes
does her tell you that she was concerned
about mr duff being violent with her at
this point
no
if she had told you that if that's
something you would have documented
in these notes
yes
um your note here states that amber has
a strong family history of drug and
alcohol abuse and is particularly
sensitive to his behaviors
[Music]
um
the phrase potential for abuse is that
referring to substance abuse
yes
it's not referring to physical abuse
no
and
what do you mean when you state that
this hurt is particularly sensitive to
mr depp's behaviors
having grown up in in that environment
she's
used to seeing the trauma that it
inflicts
and
is not only able to
um
to recognize it but also
it affects her
um
she has the ability to understand
what that looks like
and was this your observation
of her or something she told you this is
something she told me
um alex could you please pull up what's
been marked as
uh kipper exhibit five please
and
dr kipper you recognize these as
i believe you testified a combination of
your own patient notes and miss lloyd's
patient notes for mr deb correct
yes
and you and i believe you testified you
compiled them together is that right
yes
did you for the notes that were taken by
ms lloyd did you specifically request
that she maintain these notes
yes that's part of her responsibility
and do you advise her on what types of
uh information she should include in
those notes
no
is there anything in particular that you
asked her to include in the notes
no she was trained in this
and she she knew
what the
what the important metrics were
in in notation
and i believe you testified that you
have reviewed these notes in their
entirety before correct
yes
how many times would you say you've
reviewed these notes
i reviewed them at the time they were
written and i reviewed them
probably a couple weeks ago
so twice
i'm gonna turn to the last page now
and do you see this note marked on
june 30th
yes and so do you understand that to be
june 30th 2015
yes
is
did miss
did miss lloyd stop attending to mr duff
around this time
i'm going to refer to my timetable just
because i'll have a better sense of
where the treatment was
all right i'd like to talk to you uh
briefly about um the the detox process
um on mr depp's island in august 2014.
[Music]
uh i believe you said that you you
traveled down to attend to mr depp
during this time correct
yes
and
when you arrived on the island who was
who was present
mr depp miss heard
miss lloyd
and
assistance
for mr depp and i can't recall which
assistance
do you recall how many
um
[Music]
no
there were people that
i think lived or serviced that island
when he was there there were probably
four of those people
and i'm not sure if he had
one or two of his own assistance
um dr kipper um
when you arrived on the island in august
2014
did you see where mr depp was was
staying during that time
yes
and what did these accommodations look
like
he had a little
home structure it was a small
structure a
bedroom and a kitchen and a
sitting area
and was miss heard staying there with
him yes
and relative to where mr duck was
staying where was miss lloyd's thing
she was staying on another part of the
island
in a structure called a yurt
which is like a tent
and
how far away how long would it take miss
lloyd to get to
where mr duck was staying five minutes
would that be walking
no that would be on a motorized vehicle
and uh relative to where mr dub was
staying where did you sit when you're on
the island stayed on the other side of
that
okay also in a yurt
yes
um
have the deep had mr agat's
detoxification process already started
when you arrived on the island
yes
and had missed lloyd been overseeing
that
did she report any issues to you upon
your arrival
she certainly updated i was updated he
started on the 10th
i arrived on the 12th so i was in full
communication with her from the
beginning
um after you arrived on the island did
you personally oversee mr duck's
detoxification process
yes and how often would you check in on
him
um
several times a day
and was this physically going to see him
no this would be seeing him
physically once a day and then
checking
on his progress throughout the day
so during the detoxification process you
did see mr death at least once a day
yes
and
was miss lloyd checking on mr beth daley
yes
and she was seeing him in person anyway
as well
yes
you went and saw mr duck after receiving
that message correct yes
and did this like go with you
yes
and
um where did you see mr jeff after
receiving that message
i believe i saw him outside of his
little home
it was either in the
across from this little home was like a
little cantina
um where
one would eat and
it was i think in the around the cantina
and what was his physical condition at
that time
he was frustrated he was uncomfortable
how was his demeanor
uh one of being frustrated and
uncomfortable
and was miss heard with him at that time
when i saw mr depp at that point no she
was not
and at this time this was in the middle
of his detoxification process correct
yes
did you see this heard that evening
i can't remember
do you
[Music]
recall miss heard seeking medical
treatment from you for any physical
injuries while you were on the island in
august 2014.
no i don't
if ms heard had thought
treatment from you for injuries is that
something you would have documented
yes i would have
is that something you would have
remembered her telling
yes
did you see this heard after
this evening of august 8 17
on that particular evening uh that i
can't remember
but i did see miss her
pretty much daily during the time my
time on the island
so did you see her at some point
perhaps did you see her the next day
yes
and
did you observe any injuries to miss
heart at that time
no
she didn't have any bruises that you
heard
no
after you met with mr depp that evening
of august 17th
did you go back to
his accommodations at some point
no
no i think we
we resolved the
issues
where we were outside of his little
um
his home so you didn't go and attend to
him again in his home after that time no
alex could you please pull up what's
been marked as
kipper exhibit 8.
thank you uh dr kipper
i think you look you do you remember
this email from earlier in your
deposition
yes i did
and i believe you testify that you
recall sending this email to um miss
dimbroski
on august 18 2014 correct
yes
um at the time you wrote this email how
long have you known mr deb
approximately four months
and in those four months how much time
have you spent with mr death
in person
i couldn't give you a cumulative number
of hours but i would say
i would estimate
that including
up until august 18
i would i would guesstimate
20 hours
is it fair to say that when you wrote
this email most of the time you had
known mr deb or spent with mr depp was
while he was in detox
yes
during the time that you were with mr
depp on the island for his detox process
did you ever witness him physically
abused misfired
no never
did you ever see any
physical evidence that mr deaf had
abused miss hurt
no
same answer never
during your time on the island did you
witness miss heard abuse mr duck in any
way
no
um do you recall when ms heard first
became your patient
no i couldn't give you a definitive
date
it was it would have been before october
2014 though correct yes
and
it would have been
after mr duffy talks on the island in
august 2014 is that right that's great
um when you started treating ms heard
did you assign a nurse to her when when
you started treating miss heard was
there a nurse that you assigned to her
i can't recall whether it's whether
it's myers it was when i started to
treat her
at some point
i did assign a nurse to her
but i can't tell you which came first i
i believe i was treating her before
i had recommended a nurse for her
so your recollection is that you started
treating her and after that a nurse was
assigned that's that's my memory yes
do you have a sense of how close in time
to you beginning your treatment
the nurse was assigned to misheard
it couldn't have been too too long
um
but i i honestly can't give you a
specific reference of time
do you remember that nurse's name
aaron borham
and isn't this boring a registered nurse
yes
and i believe you covered this earlier
miss forum is a contractor for you
yes
but she reports to you
with respect to your patience that she
covers
correct
during the time
that ms heard was your patient and she
had a
nurse miss born was assigned to her
how
regular was miss forum
checking in with her
very regular
very regularly
saw her yes
would she have seen her on a daily basis
i don't
i don't believe it was a daily basis but
she i know had daily contact with her in
some way
would miss foreign have seen misheard in
person on at least a weekly basis
yes
there times that miss foreign
yes
and as a registered nurse does miss
foreign has an obligation to report any
suspected abuse of her patient to you
alex could you please pull up document h
okay
alex was this dog is this skipper
exhibit 34
yes
uh dr kipper do you recognize this
document
yes and what is it
um
it's it's an initial intake
of that care
i'm going to scroll down a bit
and just show you that there are
future entries on this document as well
do you see these
i do i'm
i'm assuming
i don't want to make an assumption but i
i would believe these notes are from
aaron
forum
but
if you'll give me a second to look at
this i can be more specific
certainly let me know if you'd like me
to scroll through the document a bit
more i can do that for you
yes these are notes from aaron aura
does this document reflect any of your
own notes unmisheard
this reflects my treatment
recommendations
but these are miss
oran's nose
yes
did you ask this farm to maintain these
notes
yes
and for what purpose
because she was monitoring a patient
and i needed to be informed
of how the patient was doing and
for any adjustments of treatment
did you tell ms moore what type of
information should be documented in the
notes
no
and
would there be anything that you
expressly asked her not to document
no
do you understand that mr miss boren
used her
training and judgment in preparing these
notes yes i do
you weren't telling her what to
including these notes she was
drafting them on her own is that correct
that's correct
um have you reviewed these notes before
i have reviewed these notes
have you reviewed them in their entirety
uh yes but not recently
and how often would you review miss
forum's notes on ms heard
i i review my
nurses notes as they come in so that
would be on a real-time basis
and going back to the first page do you
see this entry is dated august 27th 2014
yes
does this uh reflect refresh your
recollection as to when miss forum would
have been assigned to miss heard
yes
and does this at all refresh your
recollection as to when you started
treating ms heard
yes this would this would be about the
time
during the time that you treated miss
her did she ever seek treatment from you
for injuries that appear to be the
result of domestic abuse
no she did not
did she ever see treatment from you for
any injuries that she
told you were caused by mr death
no she did
did
not
herd ever tell you that mr duff abused
her
no she did not
and
you never witnessed
any physical abuse by mr den against
miss hurry during the time that he
treated both of them
no
no never
miss born observed that miss heard had
any physical injuries is this something
that would have been documented in her
patient notes from his heart
yes absolutely
in march 2015 you traveled down to
australia to attend deaf is that right
yes
at the time mr depp was already in
australia correct
correct
and was miss lloyd with him
yes
and was misheard with him
yes
you arrived in australia when did you
first see mr dab
i believe it was the day after i arrived
and where did you see him
i saw him
[Music]
at his home in australia
and how long did you meet with him
during that time
probably an hour
when you first met with mr death in
australia um
did you see the home that he was staying
in
yes
and was it a standalone
house
yes
was there events around the house
i'm sorry
was there a fence around the house
that i can't recall
do you recall whether mr duff security
security team was at the property
yes
they were
where did you see them
i saw them
in and around the house
do you recall how many
security personnel there were
two to three
now after you arrived in australia at
some point you were notified that mr
depp had been injured correct
yes
and i believe we you this was covered
earlier in your deposition you were
actually you actually received a text
message from mr depp correct
yes
and after you received that message did
you
go directly to mr depp
yes
and miss lloyd came with you
yes
and i believe you said that mr duff was
outside
the
property in his in a car at that time
right
that's correct
was
mr depp's security team there with him
yes
and you examined mr depp
in the car with his security team
present
yes i i saw him
seated in the car when i arrived
did mr duff tell you what had happened
to his finger
at that time
yes
how long did you attend mr death
outside of the house
not long probably
a half hour so i needed to get him to
the emergency room
so immediately after meeting him at the
house you went with him to the emergency
room
yes i cleaned his wound to the best that
i could with the supplies that we had
and then took him so it was within a
half hour that we
left you return to the house
after bringing mr duck to the hospital
no i was taken back to my hotel
you attended to mr duff and before you
went to the hospital with him did you go
inside the house
no
you did not go inside the property the
day that
mr duck
contacted you about his injured finger
no i did go into the house as i had
stated that after i saw him
initially i went into the home to see
the home
before you went to the hospital with him
yes i i went in to instruct
one of the
people with him
to look for the tip of the finger
hoping that we would be able to put it
back
was the tip of the finger found
it was found
who found it
i believe this man was their chef
and do you know where he found it or
where he told you he found it
he said he found it in the kitchen area
when you went into the house did you see
miss heard
yes
and how did he appear
she was
certainly upset
did miss hart seek any
medical attention teeth from you for any
injuries at that time
no didn't
miss her seek any medical attention from
miss lloyd at that time
no
did you observe any physical injuries to
miss her when you saw her that um
no
so this herd did not have any observable
bruises that you saw
that's correct
and
did miss hurt appear to have a broken
nose
was miss hurt's face swollen at all when
you saw her
not that i was aware of him
did miss hurt have any cuts on her arms
when you saw her
not that i can recall
did you recall seeing any cuts on her
feet or any other part of her body
i can't recall
if miss heard had appeared to have been
injured is this something that you would
have documented
yes
[Music]
did you observe any broken glass in the
house
yes
could you tell what the glass
was from
no
was there blood around the broken glass
there was blood around the home as i had
previously mentioned but i didn't
specifically see blood on
glass
where did you see the broken glass
in the kitchen area
and that's where the finger the
part of the finger was found as well
yes
um alex could you please bring up what i
believe was marked as kipper exhibit 17.
uh dr kipper you recognize this document
from earlier in the deposition
yes
it's a letter dated march 15 2015
from you to mr deb correct
and you did send this letter to mr deck
correct
correct
alex could you please pull up what i've
marked as
document k
that i believe will be
for exhibit
35.
i forget
yes
and what is it
if you could just for my verification
can you scroll down to the bottom
please
it goes on for two pages
yes i i'm i'm familiar with this
document yes
did you prepare this document
no
is this a document that was prepared by
someone who works for you
this was prepared by monroe tinker who
is a nurse practitioner who worked for
me at that time
um is this a record that's ordinarily
prepared and maintained in the course of
your business
yes
and have you reviewed this document
before
yes
when would you have reviewed it
i reviewed it immediately after the
visit
probably the next day
and i also reviewed this
um
a couple weeks ago
i'd just like to direct your attention
to the last page is this your signature
here yes
and when would you have
signed this
that was confirming that i reviewed
mr tinker's
notes
going back to the top
this is a
patient record for miss heard correct
yes
and
this where it says date december 17 2015
um
is that the date of this that's the date
of this document yes
and
the document states a phone call
consultation headache correct
yes so
does that mean that on december 17 2015
miss heard called the offices to report
a headache
yes
and right below this there there's a
paragraph that starts out with hpi
what does that stand for history of
present illness
and
is the information in this paragraph
what
ms heard reported
during her phone consultation
was written i was not there but that's
what's written
it's today the patient reports a
headache after she bumped her head while
standing up two days ago correct
yes
and
a couple sentences below that it says
last seen in the office on 12 23 2015.
is that an error
or
did you come back in later
no i think that's got to be
an error
so
based on this document it's your
understanding that ms heard
called the office on december 17.
yes
um it's going down
to the bottom here it says objective
data data physical exam do you see that
yes
um does that mean that ms heard came
into the offices for a physical
examination
that's what it signifies yes and would
that have also been on december 17 2015
yes
this note reflects that visit everything
in this note reflects that visit
and so
monroe would have also performed that
physical examination
monroe did perform that physical
examination i did not see miss heard
monroe saw mister
and the information below this heading
of physical exam which goes on to the
next page are these the the findings
from ms heard's physical exam on
december 17th
correct
and
um have miss heard any physical injuries
with those have been noted in this
portion of the document
yes
and
there are some medical terms in here but
so if you could let me know does any of
this indicate that there were
physical injuries that were documented
now
does this document indicate that a
concussion check was performed
yes
and what were the results of that
under the assessment and plan as written
um mr tinker did not indicate
concussion under his assessment
under assessment and plan item four says
that dr kipper is aware of the medical
plan and is in agreement
that's consistent with your recollection
yes
and
i believe you testified you didn't seem
misheard on december 17th correct that's
correct
how were you informed of the medical
plan
i spoke to mr tinker
by telephone
and would that conversation that
happened on the 17th as well yes
alex could you please pull up document l
and i believe this is what will be
marked as
hippo exhibit 36.
um dr kipper do you recognize this
document
uh
yes i recognize it
upon looking at it yes
what do you recognize this document as
um as an email from miss heard to me
uh requesting medical records for that
month of december
december 2015. yes
and you recall receiving this email
um i don't recall receiving it but i'm
sure i
i did and i'm sure i reviewed it
yes
and you see that the email is dated
august
8 2016 right
yes
and you have no reason to doubt that you
received the email on around that date
right
on august 8th 2016 was miss hard still
your patient
i believe so but i i can't be sure
now
i'm going to read from this email here
ms heard writes to you as per our
conversation earlier is it possible to
get my medical records
from the month of december please
i know i saw monroe during one of my
office visits if it makes it easier for
you to find
i'm not sure anyways
anyway it was great talking to you
earlier
um
[Music]
ms heard references speaking to you
earlier
in this email correct
yes
um do you recall having spoken to ms
heard before receiving this email
i can't remember
you do you don't remember anything about
a conversation that you might have had
with mr prior to receiving this email
no i i can't recall that
um
and i believe you already stated this
but you understand miss heard to be
requesting medical records from december
2015 correct
correct
and
ms heard mentions um monroe in this
email as well correct correct
and monroe is the nurse practitioner
that was heard on december 17 2015 right
yes
um
did
you provide ms heard with her medical
records for december 2015
i believe so
and
[Music]
do you recall what those records
consisted of
the one we just reviewed
was that the only one for december 2015.
again i would have to
research your chart for that information
but i know at least it was
it was that night
didn't miss herd ever ask you for any
other medical records
no
in the over six years that you've known
mr deb have you ever witnessed him be
physically abusive to any person
never
and you've never witnessed him being
physically abusive to miss her correct
correct
you've also
known miss heard for over six years at
this point correct
yes although i have not seen this for
for at least a couple years perhaps
three years
in the six years that you treated mister
in the over six years you've treated mr
deb has mr deb ever complain to you that
miss heard has physically abused him
no not that i can recall
have you ever witnessed miss heard be
physically abusive to mr death
no
has anyone who works for you or reports
to you
ever reported to you that
they witnessed misstep or excuse me
misheard be physically abusive to mr
dunn
no not that i can recall
you testified
uh
who testified earlier uh from questions
from miss myers that the tip of
mr depp's finger was found in the
kitchen
found on the floor of the kitchen and in
the home in in australia correct
right
where do you know
where the kitchen was was it on what
floor the kitchen was
there was a downstairs
below the kitchen area i think those i'm
not really sure i think those were
bedrooms but i'm not positive so this
would be on the main floor the kitchen
was on the main floor as you went into
the home
and that's where the tip of the finger
was found in the in the kitchen on the
main floor yes
no there was a text message when where
you got a text message from mr yes yes
and he said he said he cut his finger
correct
i think that's what it said yes okay and
um
the reference from the emergency room
said that mr deputy slice his finger
with a knife correct
yes that's what he told because i was
present for that that's what he told the
emergency room doctor okay so mr depp
told the emergency room doctor that he
had cut his finger with a knife correct
and you didn't put that in any of your
notes that a bottle was thrown at mr deb
correct
correct
did mr depp have any cuts anywhere else
on his face or anywhere else that would
have come from glass
now if um
if miss heard told miss borum that mr
depp had hit her in the face several
times and sent her pictures of bruises
would you expect miss born to report
that in her notes
i would have expected
this forum to send me those pictures
so you would have expected to see those
pictures from his forum is that correct
yes
and you would have expected and you
would have wanted miss forum to
if she had been seen a text that said i
was hit in the face by misheard and then
received pictures of bruises
that miss borum would report that to you
correct
yes
is that any is that an instruction that
you gave to your nurses to to report to
you any abuse that they
saw or were reported to them
yes if they saw that as valid
miss heard for example if somebody hurt
miss heard
while she was under the care uh direct
care of miss forum
uh and miss form documented that miss
heard had been injured
she certainly would have reported that
to me
that's that was that's what your
expectation would be that you can report
roger kipper did you keep any notes um
of your treatment of mr deb while he was
in australia
other than the summary notes um no
and
when
was miss lloyd with you when mr deb told
you
what had happened to his finger before
you brought him to the
i believe yes
i'm not positive but i believe yes
because she was
helping me at the car
to try to clean out that finger
which is when he explained what happened
so you believe that
that miss lloyd would have heard mr
jeff's explanation i believe so
all right that completes the deposition
and i and the next witness is also by
deposition is that correct
that's correct your honor debbie lloyd
all right well while we go ahead and go
ahead and take our morning break it's a
little early but since the next witness
is also by deposition while we take our
15-minute break now so you can
stretch for a little bit and we'll come
back
in about 15 minutes so do not talk to
anybody don't do the outside research
right okay thank you
18 minutes
okay
all right
i'm told this clock is right today so
we'll come back at 11 25. okay all right
thank you
okay
okay which one does you have a
disagreement on we might as well do it
now before we go on to the next
deposition uh sure um so the exhibit is
it's invoices from dr kipper which what
number is it
um
i'm sorry it is
1067.
that's correct and and we have no
objection to the document coming in it's
just we have a disagreement about the
redaction all right if you want to come
forward then maybe we'll take a look at
the you said 1067 correct
okay
okay sure
so
so
c
spread how are you ready for the jury
are you ready for the jury okay i just
make sure
that's right thank you
so
all right thank you
nice
just for the record i assume
juror number 10 that that's your address
to your employer because you need a
letter from your employer is that
correct okay so the court's going to do
a letter for his employer so he can be
released from work for six weeks so
that's what that
information is just for the record is
just his employer's address okay all
right thank you all right are you ready
for your next witness yes your honor mr
depp calls debbie lloyd okay but by a
video by by deposition okay
okay
california yes
and you do not live or work in virginia
correct correct
have you at any time spoken with
can you please provide your full name
deborah lynn lloyd
and miss lloyd you live in california
yes
and you work in california yes
and you do not live or work in virginia
correct correct
have you at any time spoken with
uh mr depp or any of his counsel
um
either in preparation for this
deposition or for
any other matter after
you no longer work with mr deb
yes
do you recall who you spoke to
i believe her name was camille
and do you recall when you spoke to
camille approximately
two weeks ago
and um
what did camille
can you discuss
um
she had asked me if
johnny had ever thrown anything at me
and what did you say
no
there any other
was that the
total of their communications with
camille
that was the only time that i remember
speaking to her
did you speak about anything else other
than whether um
and when you say johnny i assume you
mean mr depp correct yes
did you um
have any other with did you discuss
anything else other than whether um mr
def had thrown something at you
they had asked if i would be willing to
go to virginia to the trial
and are you willing to go to virginia to
be a trial witness no
um did you at any time did you
and
did you have any other you recall
anything else you and camille spoke
about
not in detail
do you know how long the conversation
was
approximately
approximately 15 minutes
was it over the phone yes
you recall at any other time having any
other
communications with any other counsel
for mr dab
no there was somebody else on that call
i believe from his side but i don't know
who it was
you recall if it was a man or a woman a
man
um
do you
do you ever speak to adam walton
i know an adam reached out to me a long
time ago i don't remember a last name
you were
a psychiatric mental health nurse
practitioner
yes
can you briefly explain what that is
i'm a nurse practitioner that
specializes in psych uh psychiatry
and did you go to um where'd you go to
school for that
i got my master's from maryville
university
is that in california it's in illinois
and
st louis um
sorry
no problem no problem
um
and i understand you're also a certified
addiction nurse
yes
and can you briefly explain what that is
um it's i had to get a certification
in addiction nursing
and what is addiction nursing
a nursing that specializes in taking
care of patients with chemical
dependency issues
and chemical dependency that's drugs and
alcohol yes
how long have you worked in those fields
addiction nursing and
uh mental health nurses
since
2004.
and would you agree that one of your
specialties is concierge addiction
services
it was yes
what are concierge addiction services
um we would
a good question
i mainly deal with higher um
higher end clients and provide care go
to their home rather than have them come
into facilities
and would you at times provide
24 7 nursing care yes
um
and you'd also be a patient's travel
companion
for nursing care yes
and you owned uh your own company
yes
and what was the company's name
turning point
uh do you still own turning point yes
and what does turning point do
um provides
uh services it's actually no longer i
still own it but we do i don't work with
it anymore
it provides services to
either nursing or sober companion
services to patients
and when did you start a turning point
you don't recall the exact year
uh does anyone else own it
no
how many people work at turning point
i'm the
the only employee
and what do you have contract nurses who
work for you
i did yes
and what does turning point do now
if anything
sits dormant
okay
and when did when did it
start to sit dormant
about two years ago
is there any particular reason why
that's when i became a nurse
practitioner and
changed my career path
um
and where do you work now
i work for headlands addiction treatment
services
what do you do there
nurse practitioner
and what is
there a difference between a nurse
practitioner and a nurse
nurse practitioner um i can diagnose and
prescribe medications underneath a
doctor's supervision
so when you were working at turning
point or when your own turn when you're
working at turning point were you a
nurse practitioner yeah
what what was your title then registered
nurse
and um
you
you
performed work for mr debt correct
yes
was that with turning point
turning point was contracted through dr
kipper can you explain how that
arose how you began to work for mr depp
through dr kipper
and dr kipper was his doctor and he
needed
nursing services so dr kipper reached
out to me
and it's dr david kipper
correct
um
had you worked with dr kipper before
working with mr dab yes
do you know when you started working for
mr dab
approximately
approximately
i think it was 2015 or 16.
okay
and we can we can look at some documents
and that may help um
do you know how many patients you would
work with uh with dr kipper before
working
with
mr depp
that would be a guesstimate
okay
you have any approximation
20.
um and what when dr kipper reached out
to you
about mr death
did you reach out to you by phone or by
written communication
by phone
you recall what dr kipper
told you
he was looking for in regards to mr
depp's care
uh detox
and detox from what
originally i don't think i knew any of
the specifics
what did you come to understand mr depp
was looking to detox from
opioids
any other um medication there any other
drugs that mr depp was looking to detox
from
not that i recall
you know if mr depp ever
took cocaine
i never witnessed him use any cooking
so
did dr kipper contract with your company
for care for mr deb
i
don't recall the specifics of how we
were brought on
um
well okay how were you how was how were
you paid
through dr kipper
did you
have to um
submit your time to dr kipper
for deaf services
did mr depp ever pay you directly
no
did you ever get any gifts from mr deb
yes
what gifts did you receive from mr dad
i remember getting a
jewelry box
and a um
i forget what it's called like a
notepad a fancy
notepad i guess
um it was um do you recall why
mr depp gave you the jewelry box
you can answer that
i don't know why i believed it was a
thank you
and the same uh
you believe there was a thank you for
the with the fancy notepad that you
received it was at the same time
did you receive anything else ever from
mr dab
not that i recall okay
um
do you
uh do you still do work for dr kipper
i have not recently
you recall when you last
uh
worked with dr kipper
not exactly
do you remember the year you stopped
working with dr kipper
now
you recall the last time you've spoken
to dr kipper
this week
i think
what did you talk to dr kipper about
this week
he's my personal doctor
okay
so did you speak to dr kipper at all
about um
this case
no
have you ever spoken to dr kipper about
your deposition no have you ever spoken
to dr kipper about his deposition
yes
and you know whoever gorham is correct
yes
and who is she and she's a nurse that
worked with us
and
uh miss forum worked for turning point
is that right yes
um
and she um
and did you hire
miss form
yes
was aaron was uh miss borum
a salaried employee of turning point no
so miss foreign was a contract attorney
a contract uh employee for
turning point correct fact
so how
in
kind of general sense how did that how
does that how did that work with miss
forum in turning point objection
if you needed her for a particular case
you'd hire her for that case
yes
yeah
and
you're saying your testimony is that you
had hired miss forum previously for
other patients is that right before mr
depp and miss hurt yes
um
and do you recall how um miss bohram
came to work uh for
mr depp and miss hurt
and do you recall how miss borem came to
work for mr depp and miss heard
yes
how did that happen
what happened
i was
taking care of johnny and
amber
it was decided that amber
needed some support so i brought her in
for it for amber
so
were you
mr depp's primary nurse yes
and was miss borum
amber's primary nurse yes
and would you ever
uh share responsibilities
where
uh miss borum would
perform nursing care for mr depp and he
would perform nursing care for amber
i know aaron covered for me
a few times i do not believe i ever
cared for amber
and you said that um a decision was made
that amber
needed nursing care
yes
who made that decision
i don't recall
can we put up attachment two
and we'll call this uh lloyd exhibit one
and send it
thanks
okay
i'm showing you what's been marked as
lloyd exhibit one
um
you'll see it's it's it's many pages um
and we're going to go through some of
these during the day
but just looking at it do you recognize
what what this is
yes
what is lloyd exhibit one
my nursing notes
okay and
so these are notes that you created
yes
and uh these are notes you created for
your care of mr depp is that right
correct
and if any if it'll break you want to go
over let's see the whole thing i'm um
you know i'm happy to let you do that uh
just to save time rather than having you
read a 123 pages um
but uh did you did you create these
notes in the ordinary course of business
can you clarify what that means
you created these notes
as part of your job of being a nurse
correct yes
um
did dr kipper ask you to keep these
notes
we just keep notes as nurses i don't
recall
so this is this is your normal practice
keeping these notes it's not particular
to mr depp correct correct
um
did you receive any training into how to
keep these notes
nursing school
okay
and um
the notes are
typed right
yes okay did you
[Music]
bring a laptop with you when you were um
working with mr dap
yes
well let me let's just go to the first
one it says june 12th uh 2014
2300. you see that
yes
and 2300 that's that's military time
correct yes
so that's 11 p.m at night
yes okay
and uh it says rn and md met with
patient to discuss plan and medication
re regime you see that yes okay the rn
is you correct correct
and the md is dr kipper correct
and the patient is mr depp right correct
okay
um so where it says uh
6 12 14 at 2 300 is that when you met
with mr depp or is that when you wrote
up the note
that's when i wrote up the note
okay so you may have met with mr depp at
some other time before this
sometime during that day
okay
so the the time you have here is when
you wrote the note correct okay
and would you typically
type the notes as opposed to writing
notes and handwriting and then typing
notes correct
okay um did anyone review the notes
notes were sent to dr kipper
how often would you send the notes to dr
kipper
i don't recall
and was there um a system where he could
see the notes or did you email him dr
kipper the notes
email
so
um
is it your understanding based on these
notes that the first time you met mr
depp was on june 12 2014
yes
and if we scroll down um
to the 6 13 14
um
this says you
you met with patient in his apartment
correct
so the next day you met with
mr kip mr depp in his apartment is that
right
according to my notes i don't recall
okay
and
um
in the second line
you write he stated that he
initially started taking opiates after
some dental work and became
dependent on them
um
that is is that something that mr depp
told you
according to my notes
would there be a reason you would write
that if mr depp did not tell you that
no okay
and then
you write patient is fearful of coming
off of opiates but knows it's what he
needs to do
um
so again that's something according to
your notes that mr depp told you
according to my notes yes
um and then it says patient also
expressed some emotional trauma which
causes him
depression and anxiety
again according to your notes that's
what mr depp told you
according to my notes yes
do you recall at all what the emotional
trauma
was
that was causing mr deaf depression and
anxiety
i do not recall
let me ask this again do you recall what
the plan was for mr depp's detox as of
the end of june 2014
plan in what regards
where was mr depp's detox uh going to
take place
i don't remember when it was determined
but i remember that it was after filming
we would go to the island
and that's the island that mr depp owns
yes
and you you went to the uh you went to
the island correct
who else was on the island
in this time when mr depp was doing the
detox
you can answer
i know i was there
i cannot remember if amber was there the
entire time and some of johnny's staff
and
dr kipper came at some point
how did you how did you get to mr depp's
island
flew
and then what do you take a boat
to the to his island
yes
um
and if we go to
in the same document kipper 69 which i
believe is page 17.
there we go
um
you see where it says 8 8 14
yes
and
it says arrived on island today
yes does that mean that you arrived on
the island on august 8 2014
according to my notes
okay
and on august
9th um
2014 it says patient expressed fears of
never feeling normal
without his drugs
you wrote that
yes
okay and is that something that mr depp
told you
according to my notes yes
and if we go uh
two pages
uh
kipper
oh yeah there we go
um
you see where it says uh
at the top
uh md's flight has been cancelled
yes arrangements
arrangements are being made for him to
arrive on the island 8 12 14.
um
so according to your notes dr kipper
after the flight was canceled was set to
arrive on the island on august 12 2014
according to my notes
miss lloyd i'm showing you it's been
marked as um
exhibit floyd exhibit 2 which is alh
16110 through 113.
do you remember
uh texting with amber at all while um
you were on the island with mr depp
that is
some of how we communicated yes
and does this refresh a recollection
that amber was
at least at some point on the island
with mr depp during the detox yes
the gray uh part of the text is is your
text correct
yes and the blue is amber
yes
and is in the gray part of the text um
where it shows a phone number there is
that here is that your cell phone number
yes ms lloyd i'm showing you what's been
marked as exhibit three
text message chain between
you and
amber heard on august 16th 2014
um and again the in the gray box where
it shows your a phone number that's your
phone number correct correct
and this miss lloyd i'm showing you
what's been marked as lloyd exhibit four
um
text message chain between
you and amber on august 18th 2014. you
see that
he
yes okay
if you recall one on the island amber
would be
telling you how mr duff was doing
according to these texts that's what was
happening yes
um
do you recall how long you were on the
island
i do not
um
in a day in a day do you recall how
long you would see mr death
it varied
um
would there be reasons why it varied as
to how long you'd see mr depp in a day
i don't recall what
how it was determined
how far away were you from where mr depp
was staying
five to ten minutes
by foot or by
something some other
transportation
by a john deere tractor
and where
what type of
place were you staying in on the island
it was a yurt
okay
and
you were staying with anyone
i was by myself some of the time and
then dr kipper was also in the yurt for
some of the time
and did the yurt have separate rooms
yes
and would you
would you typically uh eat with mr depp
married
um
and what was your
when you were on the island
what was your role in terms of mr depp's
detox
medication management
and what do you mean by medication
management
to administer medications
and was dr kipper
the person who was prescribing the
medications
yes
did
as part of um
the
um
medication management did mr depp get a
a bag of meds
you can answer to the extent you know
did i give mr death a bag of medications
either you or dr kipper
not that i recall
staying on this last page for a second
of lloyd four
um
the picture of uh looks like a pillbox
right
correct
did would you have provided um
either mr defrom has heard
mr depp's medications in a
box like this
yes
okay well why don't we actually just
take a break um right for this moment
we've been about an hour
um
i don't know how five minute break is
there any reason to believe where you
wrote rn received text from fiance
that that's not a text you received from
amber heard
no
lloyd exhibit 5 is a
chart of text messages we received from
in a production for mr depp um it is
death
7819
um
you see the second entry
entry 131
um yes
okay
and where in in the third
row there's your name and above that
name is the phone number is that your
phone number
yes and you
you would you would sometimes text
message with mr depp too correct
correct
um you see it says in the body on that
one
row 131
i will come by 80 within an hour to drop
meds off just in case
how are you feeling
your your head back on straight
how do you see that
i see that
and this was a text you wrote to
mr depp
according to this
do you recall
um
as of
around
august 26 2014
um what you meant by your head back on
straight
i don't recall
and then mr depp responded to you you
see in the next row
pretty much i don't have the ability to
take anything
more on my back right now
i'm [ __ ] strong if my arm is
dangerous i would cut off i would cut
the [ __ ] off i'm threatened by the
love i feel
i need to stop simple math
do you recall receiving that text from
mr deb
i don't recall
no i don't recall receiving that
you have any reason to believe you did
not receive this text from mr depp no
if we go back to
exhibit one
and if you can go to
kipper101
and you see where it says
0125 under september 22nd 2014. yes okay
and
you wrote uh rn received text from
patients stating that he'd been in an
argument with fiance
and she quote had a nasty freak out end
quote and he would like rn to come give
him some quote some [ __ ] knockout yum
yum
are an instructed patient to take prn
narotten 300 milligrams prn and seroquel
50 milligrams
and that rn was on our way over
you wrote that
yes
do you recall anything about what um the
nasty freak out
that um
mr depp was referring to about amber
i do not recall
and then you see the
note for uh 3 30
for september 22
2014
yes
okay and again that's 3 30 in the in the
morning right correct
and you wrote upon arriving at the home
patient was sitting in kitchen with
scraped and bloody knuckles on right
hand
patients stated he punched whiteboard in
kitchen after fight
patients stated he'd been texting his
friend explaining why he didn't show up
to play music and fiance got upset that
he was not giving her enough support and
the fight escalated from there
um you wrote that you wrote that no
according to this yes
do you recall
going to mr depp's home and
seeing him with
scraped and bloody knuckles on his right
hand
i do not recall
do you ever recall
any incident where mr depp had claimed
he punched a white board in the kitchen
i did not
do you have any reason to believe where
you wrote
that
you wrote upon arriving at the home
patient was sitting in kitchen with
scraped and bloody knuckles on right
hand
would you have written that based on
your observation of mr depp
yes
um on kipper 111
there's a there's a highlighted note at
19 30
for october 14th do you see that
oh wait a minute
yes
okay
and and you wrote
a patient finished filming and was
extremely agitated leaving the set
patient kicked in the door of his
trailer and refused to speak to director
patient was verbally aggressive to
another person on the set
so no apparent for no apparent reason
per
md patient is to take xanax two
milligrams to reduce his agitation at
this time you wrote that
according to these notes yes
and was were these notes based on your
observation of mr depp
i don't recall
would you go to miss would you
did you ever attend filming where mr
depp was filming
yes
um
where you wrote patient kicked in the
door of his trailer and refused to speak
to director
that's based on your observation of mr
deb
i don't recall
were you right patient was verbally
aggressive to another person on the set
so no apparent reason
um do you recall what that's based on
i do not
would it have been based on anything
other than your observation of mr deb
i don't recall
if you had been told that mr depp was
verbally aggressive would you have
written that in your note
i don't recall
and the note above it for 1630 you see
that
yes
you wrote rn and md arrived on set to
assess patient
so that's you and dr kipper
correct correct
um and you wrote patient appeared
agitated and was short towards rn
you wrote that
according to this yes
and
um
where your road patient appeared
agitated and was short
towards rn meaning mr depp was short
towards you correct
i don't remember
you that's what that's what you that's
what the note means right is there a
reason why yes yes
and this note would have been based on
your observation of mr dev at the time
correct
i don't remember
and then you see under october 15th
there's another highlighted um
entry correct
yeah
and you wrote patient awake and states
you slept from 2200 to 430. you see that
uh
yes
patient continues to be agitated about
work and is verbalizing having desire to
escape with drugs you wrote that
it's in my notes
and that would mean that you wrote that
note correct correct
and you would have written that note
based off
mr depp telling you if you had a desire
to escape with drugs correct
i'm sorry did you answer
yes i said i don't remember
and this is exhibit eight um
more text between you and mr depp um
feel free to look through it
okay
mr depp wrote i'm all i'm all right
confused as [ __ ] she said nothing of
last night and most certainly not one
thing about of the exist of the rap
party's existence
all the proof that i predicted last
night
how will i look at her when she gets
back professing her undying love all a
[ __ ] lie i for sure unfortunately
wouldn't mind some company but i have
inundated you with too much already love
love me
um that's a text you received from mr
death
i don't recall
is it at nine
um and this is um
more text between you and mr depp and
that
you can take a look through
on november 11th
2014
um mr depp wrote all good haven't read
her texts yet i'm feeling so [ __ ] why
was she at the goddamn wrap party until
5 00 am did aaron say anything the lies
are so clear now
they're making me nuts wondering what
was so interesting to keep her there
that goddamn long please ask aaron i
must have truth
i need it it's not the easiest thing to
do at this point though it's been a
shitty and painful experience
i cannot help
but hear her voice begging and crying
she wants to change and is going to
change etc
help i don't know what's real and what's
paranoiac jealousy
you received that text from mr deb
i don't recall
and you don't recall
did you recall ever mr depp not feeling
trust for amber
i don't recall
while you were working with mr depp did
he smoke marijuana
i don't recall
do you recall if you took any
if not smoke marijuana ingested
marijuana in any sort of way
i don't recall
you live at 10.
can you think of another
instance where there was a patient
without giving me the patient's name or
information
where they were
allowed to continue to take marijuana
while detoxing from
other drugs
i don't recall
exhibit 11 is is lloyd um
two through five
um do you recall producing
documents in this matter
yes
you produced uh
text messages with mr depp and with miss
heard
yes
and this um and this is a text message
between you and amber um starting on
december 26 2014. you see that yes okay
um and and you understand that you're in
the
the text from you or the blue correct
okay
all right yeah you wrote sorry to bother
you is jd up he has an important
appointment at 2pm and he isn't
responding to me hope you guys had a
beautiful christmas
and amber wrote hey there yes he is he's
opening presents with lily rose
to what appointment is he being picked
up uh who's lily rose
johnny's daughter
did you ever see mr depp super stone
when you were working with him
i don't recall
does that mean that he never saw him
stoned or you just don't recall one way
or the other i don't recall one way or
another
do you know who the wit is
amber's sister okay
do you recall any time where mr depp
seemed confused about something that had
occurred
i know
did you ever recall mr depp
wondering if he and amber had a fight or
if he was dreaming
i don't recall
do you recall mr depp ever not taking
the medications he was prescribed
yes
did you recall mr depp sometimes
potentially doubling the medications
that he was prescribed
i recall thinking that at times
did you believe that mr debt wanted to
detox off of drugs
what was your answer
yes and how did mr d how did mr duff
show you that
it was on his own free will that he
hired us to be with him
and then did mr depp have any um
relapses with drugs when you were
working with him
i don't recall
you recall mr depp and working with him
ever take
cocaine not that you necessarily saw him
but that you understood that he took
cocaine
i i never saw mr deputy's cocaine
did you have any understanding that mr
deb took cocaine
whether you saw it or not
i don't recall
did you administer drug tests to mr dap
in the beginning
did you see the results of the drug
tests
yes
did you see mr depp being positive for
taking cocaine
i don't recall
do you recall accompanying mr depp to
australia
yes
okay and you recall accompanying mr
depth to australia in around march of
2015
i don't remember dates
do you recall
accompanying mr depp to australia when
he was filming
pirates of the caribbean five
i do
where were you staying
in australia in relation to mr death
distance wise yeah how far away were you
from him
about 30 minutes
when where was mr depp staying
in a rental house
and where were you staying
in an apartment
and what what city were you in
i don't recall the name okay
and was
dr kipper there with you
he came and went
did you fly to australia with mr depp
sometimes i did and other times i flew
on a
commercial do you recall talking to dr
blaustein about mr depp in australia
i do not
do you recall mr depp not doing very
well while he was in australia
as of march 1st 2015.
i don't recall anything around that time
do you have an understanding as to what
mr depp was doing with marilyn manson
did you ever tell dr kipper that mr depp
was doing what he wants
with marilyn manson
i don't recall
do you recall marilyn manson being in
australia with mr depp
i do not
it says debbie is worried and somewhat
exhausted
do you recall being exhausted while in
australia and working with mr depp
i do not
if you have any reason to believe that
what dr kipper wrote is
not true i do not
um we can take this down
and
go back to uh
exhibit one
and if we could go to uh kipper157
you see 37 15
i do okay before i ask do you recall how
long you were in australia with mr deb
no however long the filming of pirates
was okay
and at 3 7 15 at 11 30
you wrote md received a text message
from client that he'd been arguing with
wife and that he had cut his finger
according to patient his assistant and
security were on their way to pick him
up
you wrote that
to my notes yes
is there any reason to believe you
didn't write that note
no okay
do you recall dr kipper
receiving a text message from mr depp
about mr depp cutting his finger
i don't i don't i'm just what this note
says
do you recall going to
mr depp's house
after learning that he had cut his
finger
yes
what do you recall about that
that we went to the house and
he he i i actually i don't even think i
went in at first dr kipper went in and
um he had cut his finger and we took him
to the emergency room
or his finger had been
cut
you recall what the house looked like
when you went in
yes
what did the house look like
it was a mess
hey can you describe how it was a mess
i don't remember details but i remember
there was some writing on the wall and i
remember a smash tv
do you remember what any of the writing
said on the wall
i did not
did you um and you said you were called
the smash tv
yes
okay
do you recall um
was amber in the house
i don't recall
do you recall seeing amber that day
no i don't recall
do you recall what rooms you went
through of the house mr duff's house
i remember looking for his finger in the
downstairs area
and what was in the downstairs area
but what rooms were in the downstairs
area
it was like a pool table entertainment
room
did you look anywhere else
around the house
i don't recall
what was the um
pool table entertainment room
was that a mess
i don't recall
do you recall um going into the kitchen
of the house
i don't recall
um
if you recall finding mr depp's finger
i did not
you know who found mr deb's finger
yes
ben
then who
i don't remember his last name
who was ben in relation to mr dapp
he's like our house manager
you recall
where the finger was found
i did not
do you recall if mr depp
appeared to have uh
dirt grime and paint on his hands
yes
he did
um
do you recall seeing any glass anywhere
i do not
do you recall smelling any alcohol
i do not
who else was with you when you went to
the hospital
uh malcolm
and stephen and who are malcolm
uh stephen was his assistant and malcolm
was one of his security guards
do you recall who was
holding the piece of finger that had
been cut
ben brought it to the er
what did ben bring the finger in
i don't recall
was it on ice the finger
i don't recall
did you ask mr depp how he cut his
finger
i don't recall if i asked him
did you ask anyone how mr deputy cut his
finger
i don't recall
do you have any understanding as to how
mr duff cut his finger
i heard different stories from people
what were the different stories you
heard
i had heard that amber threw a
bottle of vodka at him
i had heard that he slammed it
um with a phone
do you recall who you heard that um
amber had thrown a bottle at him i do
not you recall who you heard that he
slammed it on the phone
i do not
those the stories that you had heard
did you hear it
on that day of march 7th
uh or march 8th 2015 or later
i don't remember
did you ever talk with mr depp about how
he cut his finger
i don't recall
conversations
okay
did you ever talk with dr kipper about
how mr depp cut his finger
i don't recall specific conversations
did mr depp
um how long was mr depp in the hospital
for
i don't remember
did you have any concerns about the
supervision of mr dapp
i know at times
we would go days without me seeing him
but i don't know specifically what this
is regarding
were there issues with the nurse
supervision
while in australia
i don't recall specifics
you have no recollection of dr kipper
withdrawing his care of mr depp for any
period of time
no
i know at times it was discussed when he
would miss appointments but i don't
recall him ever actually going through
with withdrawing his care
do you recall there being concerns about
mr depp taking substances that he
shouldn't have been taking
i don't recall what that was regarding
do you recall having major concerns
about leaving for australia with mr depp
and you're not
while that's going up um miss lloyd the
day that uh mr depp cut his finger you
don't recall seeing amber one way or the
other is that right i do not
exhibit 16
um
is uh lloyd 140 145
and mr depp responded it's sad
i love you so much little debbie
and of course kipper too
he was right
though i did feel a bit of a sting when
his letter paper trail arrived on the
off chance that i croak which i also
understand
just never heard of anyone being fired
by their physician before so i'm kind of
proud of that little fact too
i love you kid even attempting saying
thank you to you would be like a monkey
trying to [ __ ] a football
it's just simply impossible
i wish things could have ended on a
better note all my love nurse shark jd
you recall receiving this text from mr
deb
i don't
this text was on your phone correct
correct
would mr def call you nurse shark
yes would mr depp call you little debbie
yes
and
okay
and you don't recall mr depp saying
never heard of anyone being fired by
their physician before
i do not
um and then you respond on the next page
i love you too and hope this is not the
end be safe and be smart my son
you send that text to mr depp
according to this yes
and you know what you meant by be safe
and be smart
i don't know
and then mr depp wrote i've i've been
off of for three days
the doc jumped the gun
also please thank him for the motrin and
the black baclofen they work a treat for
amputated fingers god damn i love that
weird [ __ ] no matter what
you receive that text from mr depp
according to this
do you understand what is meant by i
have been off of for three days i do
have no idea
okay you respond so glad to hear you
have been off no matter what i just want
you to feel better
yeah i don't know what we were referring
to
let me go down to the next page
you're right i'd be more than happy to
come back and help you with pain
management and peridol injections i know
kipper loves you and would always want
to continue your care if you're no
longer using
you wrote that to mr depp
according to this this text was on your
phone correct
correct
what did you mean by
uh kipper loves you and would always
want to continue your care if you're no
longer using
don't know just what it says
i don't know what that was regarding
you don't know what no longer using is
referring to i do not
and then mr depp wrote i don't know i'm
going to stop it all except
whatever i was on before and just deal
with it
you received that text from mr depp
yes
you know what he was referring to where
he said i'm gonna stop it all except
whatever i was on before and just deal
with it
i do not know what that's regarding
and then you wrote i respect whatever
decisions you'll make i'll be sad to
leave the crew as i love you all i hope
to always be in touch even if you choose
not to continue
a working relationship miss you already
i will get in touch with kevin and get
my stuff out
for
72 soon hugs you wrote that message to
mr depp
according to this okay
and then mr depp wrote take care darling
i cannot ever thank you enough all
you've done for me on the junky side and
the broken heart side
you've been a lifesaver literally we'll
be seeing each other again sweetheart
love you so much little debbie and so
does my entire crew x you receive that
text message from mr depp
according to this yes i'm gonna cry it's
miss lloyd i'm showing you what's been
marked as uh exhibit lloyd17 uh which is
lloyd 158 through 160.
um
which is a text message between you and
johnny depp
from your phone you see that
yes
okay
and um
on march 27 2015
um you wrote uh
good morning sleepyhead aaron came by to
give you a shot
you were still sleeping um take the pill
form of
tutorial to hold you over and i'll check
in with you when i've done my
appointment in beverly hills
uh and then you wrote have you taken
pill if not hold off and aaron is on her
way to give you injection do you see
that
yes okay
and you wrote that text message correct
for those messages
yes okay and then on the next page
um
mr depp wrote the [ __ ] pain is as bad
as when it was cut off
horrific
uh you received that message from mr
depp
yes and he's talking about his his
finger there correctly yes and you
received that text message from amber
correct correct right
and then you wrote he's at the studio
with marcus and is supposed to call me
when he gets back
to the lofts i will drive up there if
you want me to always feel weird showing
up unexpected
do you want me to go you wrote that text
message to amber
i don't recall but according to this yes
do you know who marcus is
uh yes
who is marcus
marcus mumford
and and what was his relationship to mr
deb
friend okay and then you wrote
i know stephen is there let me just
check in and see what i can find out
i'll get right back to you
who is stephen
his assistant
do you ever remember checking if mr
death had been taking cocaine
i don't remember specifically asking any
questions related to that
is there any reason to believe that you
didn't do what you said in your text
message
no
do you recall what you were giving mr
death valium for
i do not
miss lloyd showing you again at what's
been marked as exhibit one and i'm going
to point you to um
kipper 167
which is from april 13 2015
okay
okay do you see it you see the the entry
for 1500
yes
all right
um
you wrote um bandage changed and hand
exercises done at appointment with
surgeon's office
per rn at surgeon's office and
occupational therapist hand is healing
well and finger has good range of motion
exercises to be done three to five times
per day
patient is in good spirits and said he's
not smoked marijuana in three days
states he feels majority of his issues
with his wife have been
from him using drugs and alcohol
patience states he will no longer sneak
use and wants to enjoy clary
you wrote you wrote that
yes
and these are part of your nurses notes
yes
and mr death told you that he felt the
majority of his issues with his wife had
been from him using drugs and alcohol
according to the note yes
and mr depp wrote he will no longer
sneak use and wants to enjoy clarity
according to the document yes
um what is being referred to as no
longer sneak use
i only know what's stated in my
notes
okay would it be anything other than
drugs or alcohol
i don't recall
was there anything
that mr depp was sneaking other than
drugs and alcohol that you were
concerned about
i don't recall
if we go to uh 175 kipper 175 on this
page on this document um
it's
notes for june 28 2015
um
it talks it says at 1700 rn received
initial results from brain mri no
obvious abnormalities noted
final report will be done tomorrow
patient informative results
do you recall why mr depp received the
brain mri
he was having chronic headaches
and then you see it six at 6 30 at 1300.
yes
okay
um and that's and that's highlighted
yeah
okay
um
you wrote rn arrived on set to visit
patient
he was upset due to having an argument
with his wife
patients stated he had taken about
four's annex one milligram over the past
24 hours to deal with the stress he was
feeling
patient was able to express his emotions
appropriately the patient stated that he
had not slept the night before due to
argument with his wife
that's a note you wrote
correct
and that's based off of information
provided to you by mr deck
i don't recall
well we're according to my note yes
so mr depp told you he'd taken about
four xanax one milligram over the past
24 hours correct into my notes yes
okay and then at
um
1920
on june 30th it said patient had another
argument with his wife
patient was anxious and was asking for
medication to help calm him down
sarah call 50 milligrams administered
you see that
and that's a note you wrote yes
do you know why your nursing notes ended
on june july 1st
2015.
i do not
how did you continue to care for mr depp
as his
nurse after july 1st 2015
i do not recall my last date
did you prepare nursing notes
through the time that you were mr depp's
nurse i did okay
and did you provide those notes to dr
kipper
i did
this lloyd i'm showing you what's been
marked as exhibit floyd 19.
this is an email from
dr david kolber on june 27 2015
that you were copied on do you see that
yes
and do you know who dr culver is
i don't recall exactly who he was
um did you understand that mr depp went
to a
specialist first finger
yes
okay
you're copied on this email i see my
name copied on the email yes okay and
you recall the doc that uh mr depp was
treated for a bad crush injury for his
finger
i recall him being treated for a finger
injury
i didn't realize
this is the first i remember hearing it
was a crush injury
and that's the email you received from
dr culver correct
i'm seeing this today i don't recall
receiving this email
is there any reason you believe you
didn't receive this email no
i just don't recall
ms lloyd i'm showing you what's been
marked as exhibit 20
which is a text message chain between
you and mr depp from your
phone you see that
i see that
um
on july 5th 2015 mr depp wrote to you
canceling the squeezing and need needles
tonight need to get
the recluse out of his cage and his
brain you receive that text message from
mr depp
yes
and then you said
how how come you're canceling you okay
not sure what you mean by the rest
of your text
please let me know if you need anything
i'm here if you want to chat or want me
to go hang
at the house with you you wrote that
text to mr depp
yes
and then mr depp wrote to you
i'm in a very anxious and painfully
confused state
rather not get into details
but in a nutshell problems with family
my company the ex business manager and
my [ __ ] jumbled brain will need
refills of meds tomorrow thanks honey x
you received that text from mr depp
according to this yes okay and mr depp
talked about how he was having problems
with his family
that's what this states
and mr depp was having problems with his
company
that's what this states and mr depp was
having problems with the ex
that's what to say
and mr depp was having problems with his
business manager
according to this text
and mr depp was having trouble with his
[ __ ] jumbled brain correct according
to this text
i'm just going back to exhibit one
for a moment
we can go back to kipper 167
and miss lloyd um
i'd ask you to look at the uh
entries
for
april 14th
the bot is at the bottom
okay
um
you wrote at 1400 rn and md arrived
patient's home to have meeting to set
treatment plan and boundaries while
traveling in australia
you wrote that
and the rn is you correct
yes and the md is dr kipper correct
and do you recall what the treatment
plans and boundaries were while
traveling in australia as of
april
uh 2015.
i do not recall
and then if we go to the next page
um you see the april 15
entries
yes okay
and
at 12 15 you write
arrived at patient's home
assistant was in hallway and informed rn
that patient was in a bad mood and told
the assistant he did not need anything
from him today
aaron was led in home by security and
knocked on patient's door to let him
know she was there patients screamed
what
are an informed patient she was letting
him know she was there and would be
downstairs
about five minutes later security came
into house and informed rn the patient
has told security to get everyone out of
his home and he did not want any more
unexpected guests
rn left property and informed md of the
events
per md drop tomorrow meds off with
security and do not reach out to patient
again wait for p patient to reach out to
medical full team
you were with that note correct
and this document also this note also
talks about you informing dr kipper
about what happened that
in this note correct yes
lloyd i'm showing what's been marked as
lloyd
um you see at april 15th at the bottom
there's a text from
mr depp
yes
and he wrote hey sweetheart i'm so sorry
about today i thought you were stephen
whom i'm not
particularly enthused about for his loss
of loyalty and his loss of memory he has
tried everything to [ __ ] me over as far
as traveling with my wife he also bursts
into my [ __ ] house like it's goddamn
grand central station i'm truly sorry if
i upset you if you like you can give me
some morphine to see if my tongue and
penis touch all my love jay
did you receive this text from mr death
uh might appear so
i know yes
okay
um do you
do you have any understanding as to what
mr depp was referring to where he says
um
steven tried everything to [ __ ] me over
as far as traveling with my wife
first of all um going back to um your
work for dr kipper um
you said
i think you testified earlier you care
for multiple patients that were of dr
kippers correct correct
and um when you would care for dr
tipper's patients how would you
um
report their status to dr kipper
objection vague
uh multiple different resources
phones texts verbal tech verbal and
written
and how often would you report to dr
kipper about his vision
it responded
i mean it
depended on different patients
varied
and i believe you testified earlier that
you maintain nursing notes for those
patients correct
correct what type of information did you
maintain in these nodes
mainly we provide a care given and
patients responses to care given or any
external factors that could
affect the patient
is there any information that you would
not include in your notes
not
i'm sorry i didn't catch your answer
not specifically
other than dr kipper does anyone else
review your notes
if another nurse was to work on the case
they could
have access to the notes
and
does dr kipper advise you on any
information that should be
maintained in your notes
not directly
has he ever told you that certain
information should not be included in
your notes
no
how long have when did you um become a
registered nurse
2004
and have you been employed as a
registered nurse um
from that time up until you became a
nurse practitioner
yes
in your time as a registered nurse have
you ever had a patient that you
suspected was the victim of domestic
abuse
no
do you have any professional
responsibility to uh report domestic
abuse
yes
and what is that responsibility
i'm a mandated reporter for child elder
abuse
and
any suspected injuries
how would you define suspected injuries
if i was to work in a facility and
somebody came in and reported or i felt
that it was a result from
an injury caused by somebody else
um
who do you report the abuse to in that
instance
i've never had to report abuse
okay do you but um given your
professional responsibility do you know
who you would report that to in that
event
i do not
um in your time as a registered nurse
have you ever witnessed physical
violence um by one of your patients
i do not recall ever witnessing any
violence
and when you say any violence does that
mean perpetrated by your patient or
against your patient or just
just in general violence
so you met mr deb
either on june 11th or june 12th of
2014.
according to him i know yes
have you ever spoken with him before
that date no
uh when did you first meet miss heard
i don't recall
do you recall when you first met her not
specifically when but do you recall the
instance when you first met her i do not
when you uh first met ms hurst did you
have an understanding as to what her
relationship to mr deaf was at that time
yes
and what was that understanding
that they were in a relationship
were they engaged when you first met
them
i don't i don't recall the dates they
got engaged
were they married when you first met
them no
did you attend their wedding yes
and where was that on
the island in the bahamas
um can we take this down and please pull
up
what i've marked as document b
23
now just for the record um
i believe these are the nursing notes
you were looking at earlier
um this is just has a different um
production number and i just thought it
might go more smoothly if i i'm calling
out the correct page number so um
just to establish this do you recognize
this document here yes
and these are your nursing notes that um
i believe you looked at with with mr
needle hop earlier
correct okay
um
i'd like to direct your attention to the
um entry for june 17th of 2014 which is
on
engage with
perfect there it is
um
this is the note you prepared correct
correct
and
at the time that you prepared this note
were you in
boston with mr depp
according to the note yes
now in the subsection that says
2
23 30
um do you see where it says accompanied
patient fiance
assistance and security to concert
yes
okay and in this note patient refers to
mr depp is that right
yes
and beyonce is misheard yes
this reflect refresh your recollection
that uh mr deaf and ms heard were
engaged in june of 2014
according to this yes
um
is this the first time you met miss
heard
i don't recall when i met her
um further down in the note do you see
where it says assistant was also asked
to pass on rn and md's numbers to fiance
as we would both like to speak with her
and to obtain her input towards patient
treatment
you see where i'm referring to yep
okay
um
rn is referring to you in this instance
correct
and
um md refers to dr kipper correct
um
do you recall why he wanted to speak
with miss hurd at this time
i do not
um
do you recall miss hart expressing
interest in participating in mr depp's
treatment
i don't remember the events other than
what stated in my notes
your phone number was given to ms heard
though correct correct
so 24.
um
lloyd do you recognize this document
so i think that you did not prepare this
document is that correct correct
um
ladies and gentlemen that's probably a
good break to go ahead and have our
lunch break so we'll go ahead and break
until two o'clock to not discuss the
case with anybody known to me outside
research okay we'll come back and
continue this deposition
all right
so it's return at 2 pm correct
okay thank you
you